démarrer nos
travaux capé aujourd'hui oui nous
poursuivons les travaux de la commission
d'enquête sur les moyens mobilisés
mobilisables par l'État pour assurer la
prise en compte et le respect par le
groupe Total énergie des obligations
climatiques et des orientations de la
politique étrangère de la France dans ce
cadre nous entendons aujourd'hui
monsieur syvain vasserman président
directeur général de
l'ADEM agence a un rôle central dans la
mise en œuvre des politiques publiques
dans les domaines de l'environnement de
l'énergie et du développement durable
laadem est en particulier engagé dans le
financement de projets relatifs à
l'efficacité énergétique et au
développement des énergies
renouvelables avant de vous laisser la
parole pour un propos introductif d'une
quinzaine de minutes il me revient de
vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat la vidéo sera le
cas échéant diffusée sur les réseaux
sociaux puis consulta en vidéo à la
demande elle fera l'objet d'un
contteendu
public je rappelle en autre qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 14 15 du
code pénal qui peuvent aller de 3 à 7
ans d'emprisonnement et de 45000 à
100000 € d'amende je vous invite
maintenant à prêter serirement de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure je le
jure avant de vous céder la parole je
vous invite à nous préciser si vous
détenez des intérêts de toute nature
dans le groupe Total ennergie ou chez
l'un de ses concurrents dans le secteur
de l'énergie y compris sous forme de
prestation de conseil ou de
participation à des à des cénacles
financés par les
énergéticien alors je mettez le micro
allez-y allez-y ah oui voilà pardon
excusez-moi monsieur le Président dans
cette déclaration d'intérêt je voulais
vous rendre compte de ce que j'ai mis
dans ma déclaration à la haat TVP qui
est ce que je je produis évidemment dans
le cadre de mes
fonctions sur la partie patrimoniale
j'ai trois actions de l'entreprise que
j'ai dirigé il y a 10 ans qui s'appelle
réseau gaz de Strasbourg qui est dans le
domaine de l'énergie qui
s'était dont j'avais lancé les filiales
de production de méthane et de de réseau
de à l'heure c'est à l'époque que j'ai
rencontré laadem et puis j'ai des fonds
d'assurance vie mon épouse et moi qui
s'appuie sur les alors qui sont liés à
des banques sur des produits classiques
mais dont certains sont indexés sur la
santé de l'économie européenne et
française donc je ne sais pas comment il
le gère mais bon c'est des produits
marché de placement d'assurance vie pour
la déclaration d'intérêt je suis je suis
en déport sur les clients que j'ai eu
dans mon
activité préalable à ma nomination
euh à l'ADEM au travers lorsque je
faisais du conseil après avoir été
député et donc j'ai trois clients sur
lequel je suis en en déport un client
qui s'appelle PRIMEO qui fait de
l'électricité sur la zone de Saint-Louis
qui est un opérateur
local filiale d' d'un groupe suisse
et le la branche haut de suè que j'ai eu
comme client pour les accompagner dans
le débat sur la la avec la CNDP euh
Commission nationale du débat public sur
un projet de majeur dans dans le domaine
de l'eau ainsi qu'une petite entreprise
de la MTech alssacienne qui n'a rien à
voir avec le sujet du jour voilà je
tenais à vous en faire part et bien je
rappelle je rappelle également pour la
bonne connaissance de chacun que vous
étiez parlementaire député de 2017 à
2022 votre réponse sera donc mentionnée
au compteendu tel quel
très rapidement et avant de laisser le
questionnement du rapporteur puis des
membres de la commission
qui qui est là ou qui seront là d'ici
tout à
l'heure pour orienter not votre propos
introductif je souhaiteris vous
interroger au sujet du rapport
transition 2050 que l'ADEM a réalisé qui
définit des scénarios des scénaris afin
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 à votre avis quel mix énergétique
permettra à la France de mener à bien
cette transition énergétique ça veut
dire que faire des grospes producteurs
d'énergies fossile comment décarboner
les énergies fossiles et un simple
élément l'ADEM a été en en lien direct
avec total pour un programme de mémoire
de 2009 à 2013 quelle conclusion vous
tirez de ce programme je sais que vous
êtes à nouveau en lien avec total sur
différents programmes C ces années-ci
comment vous voyez les choses allez-y
pour votre propos introductif merci
monsieur le Président alors
effectivement peut-être pour commencer
d'un point de vue technique à mon sens
ça ne fait pas partie de la déclaration
d'intérêt mais bien de la description
des flux financiers qui peut y avoir
entre toutes les entreprises et laadem
et en particulier total euh il y a
quatre quatre domaines donc je les cite
brièvement et je serai à votre
disposition si vous avez des questions
sur le sujet les aides à la
décarbonation qu'on peut faire pour des
sites français de Total typiquement ils
ont un site en France ils veulent le
décarboner et comme toutes les autres
entreprises on peut aider un projet de
décarbonation ça c'est le premier point
euh alors on c'est pas forcément laadem
peut être coopérateur d'une décision qui
est prise notamment dans le cadre de
programme comme France 2030 sur lequel
il y a une comitologie de décision mais
nous on va instruire le dossier donc ça
c'est le domaine des aides le deuxième
domaine c'est le domaine des C2E alors
là il est très générique c'estàdire que
tous les tous les obligés total est un
obligé donc il il a des dépenses
obligatoires euh dans des domaines de
décarbonation et là laadem peut
bénéficier de fonds notamment sur le
vélo ou sur euh l'accompagnement de des
transporteurs en logistique euh donc
laadem gère des programmes et les
obligés financent ces programmes donc
total euh finance beaucoup de programmes
dont quelques-uns j'aurais liste exacte
qui peuvent être opérés par la deMM 3è
point d'interaction euh l'onpe euh sur
la précarité énergétique ils sont comme
beaucoup d'entreprises contributeur à
hauteur de 90 € 90 k€ pardon à l'onpe et
puis je voulais signaler également que
le président de l'ADEM siège au Conseil
national de l'énergie dans lequel siège
également total voilà je crois avoir
cartographié je suis évidemment à votre
disposition d'ailleurs il y aura les
détails dans le document écrit qui est
pas encore prêt on a jusqu'à fin février
pour le le rédiger euh on n' pas encore
eu ayant eu les questions en fin de
semaine dernière on n' pas encore eu le
la possibilité de vous le fournir donc
on essaiera de le faire enfin on le fera
évidemment avant avant
l'échéance pour répondre à votre
question monsieur le Président euh je
voudrais commencer par dire que la
vocation de l'ADEM dans les scénarios
qui ont été construits c'est bien sûr la
diminution de la part du fossile qui
reste très importante aujourd'hui euh
dans nos dans nos modèles euh la la dans
les scénarios déjà de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie
euh donc qui n'est pas un scénario
strictement Adem mais dont l'ADEM s'est
inspiré pour rédiger les quatre
scénarios de 2050 de qui sont des
chemins possibles pour atteindre les
objectifs de neutralité carbon et de
décarbonation euh on a un objectif de 74
% de baisse pour le pour le pétrole et
56 % pour le pour le gaz naturel donc
ces objectifs quels que soient les
scénarios sont des objectifs de baisse
importantes euh des fossiles et toute
notre activité une grande partie de
notre activité c'est justement de
travailler sur cette baisse des des des
énergies fossiles jeais quand même
rappeler quelques éléments que que j'ai
pu compiler dans les information que
nous que nous gérons à
laadem bon le le le le le code de
l'énergie prévoit 40 % de moins sur les
énergies fossiles en énergie primaire
pour 2030 ne fixe pas encore d'objectif
de 2005 50 ce sera dans
snb3 stratégie nationale bacarbone
numéro 3 qu'on aura les objectifs pour
2050 euh on a nous quatre scénarios de
référence qui sont des chemins possibles
pour atteindre la décarbonation tous ces
scénarios amènent à une baisse drastique
de la consommation d'énergie finale en
en
fossile qui passerait d'environ 60 %
aujourd'hui à à moins de 20 % dans tous
les scénarios
euh voilà donc ça ça c'est c'est c'est
l'activité globale de laadem qui en fait
a une action massive d'accompagnement de
tous ceux qui prennent le chemin de la
décarbonation que ce soit des
collectivités ou que ce soit des
entreprises dans cette logique là on
intervient je vis peut-être signaler les
les les grandes logiques d'intervention
de laadm la première c'est au côté de
l'industrie et des entreprise sur la
décarbonation de l'industrie il y a
beaucoup de projets sur lequel des
acteurs économiques n'ont pas d'intérêt
économique à basculer en décarbonation
pas d'intérêt immédiat et les
financements de l'État puisque laadem
évidemment c'est une évidence mais je le
dis pour ceux qui pourraient nous
écouter c'est une agence de l'État donc
les fonds sont des fonds de l'État euh
que qu'on a la responsabilité
d'instruire de gérer parfois de décider
sur certains sujets parfois d'opérer sur
d'autres donc pour la décarbonation de
l'industrie euh c'est une ce sont des
projets importants on on a des exemples
de alors on évalue à peu près à à à
8,5 millions pardon 8,5 TWh d'économie
fossile qui ont été permises grâce au
projets que nous avons accompagné en
décarbonation de l'industrie pour donner
quelques ordres de grandeur il faut
préciser et j'aurai l'occasion de le
redire sur la la logique des aides qu'on
aide un projet donc la clé de lecture de
nos ingénieurs qui instruisent des
dossiers ce n pas de savoir si la
collectivité par exemple active
pleinement son levé fiscal et si elle a
beaucoup de ressources financières ou
pas c'est pas de voir si l'entreprise
fait beaucoup de profit et qu'elle verse
des dividends ou pas c'est vraiment de
d'évaluer un projet sur son impact
climat et donc de l'aider si l'impact
climat évidemment est positif et de se
mettre au niveau d'aide qui permet de
rendre à l'équilibre d'unun d'un TER
acceptable le projet donc on raisonne
par projet la seule condition c'est
évidemment l'éligibilité à des aides
d'État donc ça peut pas être une
entreprise en en statut en difficulté
mais sinon il y a pas d'évaluation j'ai
envie de dire autre que l'efficacité du
projet pour le climat avec des objectifs
d'efficacité
d'euros investi puisque le le
l'indicateur clé qui permet d'évaluer
les projets c'est en quelque sorte
l'efficacité de l'euro public investi au
regard du nombre de tonnes de carbone
économisé qui nous permet d'évaluer
projets par projet en instruisant ces
dossiers euh et euh qui qui aboutissent
à à à une aide ou pas certains
programmes dans la décarbonation de
l'industrie on est aujourd'hui sur un
programme essentiellement France 2030
qui est une comitologie qui n'est pas
une décision de l'ADEM en revanche c'est
l'instruction euh et les flux financiers
et le le caractère euh caractère
mécanique du versement du contrôle de et
puis de l'instruction du dossier qui
revient à laadem la comitologie est en
celle de du SGPI et de France
2030 le deuxième fond le plus important
c'est le fond chaleur le fond chaleur il
est des collectivités qui vont faire le
choix d'une
infrastructure énergétique pour irriguer
leur territoire une infrastructure de
réseau de chaleur euh donc on est là sur
des des logiques importantes avec une
très forte croissance des budgets il
était il y a 2 ans aux alentours de 300
millions l'an dernier aux alentours de
500 millions cette année aux alentours
de 800 millions donc là ce sont des
projets de territoire sur lequel en
général par mode de délégation de
service public une
collectivité lance sa DSP fait son choix
de de l'entreprise par exemple qui
publique ou privé qui va gérer le réseau
et nous on intervient pour ajuster
l'équilibre économique du réseau de
chaleur et à hauteur de de de
l'équilibre
économique voilà donc ça c'est le
deuxième fond massif d'investissement
après on a beaucoup d'appels à projet on
en a sur le transport notamment sur la
mobilité lourde on a accompagn beaucoup
de projets qui étaient soit
d'électrification de poids lourd puisque
c'est une tendance forte qu'on ressent
aujourd'hui on avait lancé un appel à
projet de de poil lour électrique qui a
eu un grand succès et qu'on a qui a été
reconduit
cette année et à chaque fois ce qu'on
regarde c'est
donc le nombre de tonnes de carbone
économisé qui est un peu notre notre
critère pour évaluer un projet par
rapport à un
autre peut-être donc ça c'est le la
première partie de ce que je voulais
partager avec vous la deuxième partie du
propos était plus centrée sur total je
sais pas si vous souhaitez que je le
fasse maintenant euh donc ça nous
intéresse oui enfin c'est le sujet he
dans les questions que vous m'avez posé
donc donc j'y viens assez assez
naturellement euh d'abord je vous
rappelle que les entreprises total a
l'obligation de de déposer le bilan de
gaz à effet de
serre tous les 4 ans donc ils sont à
jour de leur de leur bilan c'est l'ADEM
qui collecte l'ensemble de ces bilans et
qui qui le gère la mécanique de tout ça
avec avec dans leur structure déclaré
hein et d'ailleurs publique qui est
consultable sur son bilan gaz à effet de
serre quelques particularités qui me
semblent importantes à préciser euh le
le l'activité de gaz à effet de serre se
se structure avec les fameuxes SCOP 1 2
3 pour parler en bon français en tout
cas des des des des impacts directs ou
indirects euh sur le le carbone il se
trouve que pour un opérateur comme Total
le scope 1 et 2 qui va inclure notamment
toutes leurs activités de production de
raffinage toute le leur processus
industriel ne représente que 5 % de
leurs émissions à peu près puisque
d'après leur leur déclaratif on est euh
globalement à au niveau mondial 40
millions de tonnes de CO2
euh au niveau du scope 1 1 1 et 2 en
vant le scope 3 qui est l'impact des
produits vendus donc par exemple quand
ils vendent des carburants qui servent
dans une voiture
euh là euh c'est 389 millions de tonnes
donc on a évidemment une une une
représentation forte du scope 3
et un poids fort du scope 3 dans le dans
dans le le l'impact carbone de Total
euh l'IMP l'impact carbone total c'est
400 millions de tonnes au passage c'est
l'équivalent des émissions de la France
donc au point de vue mondial le total
scope 1 2 et 3 quand on somme l'ensemble
des scopes je rappelle pour pour être
bien clair que le scope 3 c'est de
l'indirect c'est l'impact par exemple du
carburant qu'ils
vendent il faut bien comprendre que nous
et d'ailleurs les plans de décarbonation
qui peuvent avoir lieu entre entre
l'État et et et total concerne
l'activité en France donc les sites les
plus carbonés en France donc dans le
scope 1 2 des 5 % dont je parlais tout à
l'heure et c'est ça qui fait l'objet en
fait des aides de
décarbonation qui peuvent être octroyés
à Total comme à tous les industriels
pour décarboner les sites qui sont
présents en France je tenais à le
préciser parce qu'évidemment sinon on on
risque de faire des erreurs d'analyse
nous c'est bien ce périmètre là qu'on
qu'on regarde le deuxème point c'est que
dans leur plan de
transition ils ont une volonté de de
diminuer de 40 % et j'y reviendrai les
scopes 1 et 2 et c'est sur ça qu'on peut
qu'on accompagne au travers des
différents projets de décarbonation
la question qui vient juste après c'est
de se dire quel est leur plan de
décarbonation leur trajectoire alors
là-dessus l'ADEM n'a pas d'avis en tant
que tel parce que un avis de l'ADEM
c'est quelque chose de très précis c'est
une étude avec des ingénnieurs qui ont
tout un processus scientifique pour
publier un avis en revanche on a
eu on a porter à notre connaissance des
éléments qui concernent l'évaluation qui
ont pu être fait sur total alors
pourquoi parce que il se trouve que on a
nos nos ingénieurs on ont construit une
méthodologie qui s'appelle acte
évaluation acte en bon français pour
assessing carbon transition donc évaluer
les trajectoires de décarbonation donc
ça s'appelle acte évaluation et cette
méthodologie elle est française mais
elle est aussi internationale et que du
coup notre partenaire qui s'appelle
World benchmarking alliance notre
partenaire international qui gère les
évaluations les évaluations de acte
évaluation au niveau
international ont évalué l'ensemble des
des acteurs oil and gaz donc du du
domaine d'activité totale don total et
donc on a eu cette notation à notre
connaissance puisqueévidemment étant
étant associé avec eux d'ailleurs ce
sont des données publiques que cette
association
publie donc du
coup faire un petit zoom sur les
résultats à la fois de cette
évaluation de la la trajectoire de
totale c'estàdire l'avis qui a pu être
émis sur la base de notre méthodologie
acte évaluation à propos du groupe Total
ainsi que le les évaluations qui ont pu
être fait par le forum investissement
responsable sur leur exercice de se on
climate qui est donc l'information qu'il
donnent à leurs administrateurs euh sur
leur trajectoire de décarbonation donc
c'estes deux éléments qui ont été portés
à notre connaissance et donct je pense
il faut que je vous rendre compte
puisque ça fait partie des éléments
qu'on a sur total sans en être encore
une fois euh les évaluateurs
nous-mêmes euh le premier point concerne
leur objectif euh de de
décarbonation sur leur objectif de
décarbonation alors euh leur trajectoire
donc a donné une note et à la fois le
WBA et à la fois le fir ont noté avec
notre méthodologie total comme ils ont
noté les 400 principal 400 principales
entreprises duland gaz deux deux
conclusions assez convergente l'un ayant
alors la méthodologie Act se compose
d'une note sur 20 qui est qui qui est le
premier élément et puis après d'une
lettre et d'une tendance ser un peu long
de le le déployer mais en tout cas ils
ont eu 7,6/ 20 en terme de note pour
l'un des évaluateurs WBA et 7/ 20 pour
le le deuxème évaluateur qu'est-ce qui
fait cette notation alors cette notation
est assez basse mais c'est ils sont
numéro 3 ou numéro 7 suivant les
classements et suivant ce qu'on prend
par rapport à l'ensemble des entreprises
gaz qui ont été évolé avec une note
faible sur les 400 c'est 400 je crois
combien ah 100 pardon c'est 100 je suis
désolé c'est 100 entreprises donc il
sont 3e ou 7e alors évidemment le oil
and gaz il y a pas de surprise que les
trajectoires de décarbonation euh bah
sont pas à la hauteur
euh puisque puisqueévidemment notamment
total a des à des logiques de continuer
l'activité évidemment de de vente de
carburant qui structure beaucoup son
scope 3 et donc on a des objectifs de de
trajectoire qui sont grosso modo 40 %
en 2030 sur le scope 1 et 2 et une
stabilité à 400 million de tonnes de CO2
sur le scope 3 c'est l'objectif à 2030
avec un objectif à 2050 d'un
net0 et avec un concept de carbone
important pour atteindre des objectifs
donc de de captation de
carbone qui relève de la logique de
compensation pour nous la compensation
c'est vraiment du dernier recours
dans dans dans cette stratégie là c'est
bien d'avoir une compensation il vaut
mieux éviter toujours enfin n on a
toujours tendance à dire il vaut mieux
éviter qu'avoir à compenser enfin s'il y
a des émissions il vaut mieux
compenser donc on est dans cette logique
là donc une note assez faible en valeur
absolue mais parmi les tout meilleurs de
de la centaine d'entreprises que qui qui
ont été évalué notamment par
WBA dans cette logique là sur les trajet
trectoire et puis après je passerai
peut-être parce que je dépasse un peu
les 10 minutes je m'en
excuse sur les trajectoire ce qui est
important également de de partager avec
vous j'ai bien indiqué que c'est que que
le scope de nos interventions c'est le
périmètre français et non pas le
périmètre mondial de total c'est un
point qui me semble qui me semble
majeur et que nous travaillons avec
Total au travers
des des plans de décarbonation
sectoriell c'est qu'on partage avec nous
un C N d'information pour voir mais ça
c'est un travail en cours pour voir nous
établissons des des plans
sectoriels pour
pour
évaluer des plans de transition
sectoriel pour évaluer la transition des
des des des différents pans de
l'économie par famille donc il y en a un
notamment sur lequel on travaille avec
eux pour essayer de comprendre comment
les les les acteurs de de de leur
domaine d'activité peuvent prendre le
chemin de la décarbonation on estime et
pourquoi la note est si basse on estime
enfin plutôt on l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie estime qu'il faudrait que
les acteurs du oil and gaz investissent
jusqu'à 77 % de leur capacité
d'investissement sur la décarbonation
pour atteindre les trajectoires
euh de décarbonation aujourd'hui les
acteurs sont nettement de ça et c'est ça
qui qui fait que la note est assez
faible en valeur absolue ils sont aux
alentours d'une quinzaine de pour si on
regarde al il faut faire très attention
en fonction des périmètres parce que
quand on dit total
énergie grosso modo on est dans cet
ordre de grandeur là et donc évidemment
la notation pénalise le fait que les
moyens
d'investissement ne sont pas suffisants
au regard de ce
que ce qui est attendu en matière de
d'investissement pour pour une
décarbonation
pour peut-être conclure et et et et
vous vous répondre aux question que vous
pourriez avoir je voudrais finir le tour
peut-être des des deux points euh des
deux points suivants que j'ai aborder à
savoir les aides que laadem peut
apporter à total pour vous donner
quelques alors il y aura la liste de
toutes les aides tout ça tout ça est
public hein bien sûr donc euh il y a eu
dans les les 5 dernières années euh 38
millions d'euros qui ont été à à à à
Total ou ses filiales en réalité c'est
28 + 10 je m'explique il y a une filiale
de Total qui s'appelle Saft qui avait
été beaucoup aidé à hauteur de 100
millions mais avant qu'elle qu'elle soit
dans le groupe Total donc il y a eu des
aides qui ont été octroyées à cette
filiale qui fait des batteries je crois
euh qui avait été octroyé avant qu'elle
soit dans le groupe Total donc c'est 28
millions si on prend uniquement groupe
Total et 38 millions dans sa figuration
actuelle après le rachat et leur prise
de participation dans dans Saft euh les
programmes ont été essentiellement de la
récupération de chaleur fatale de la
décarbonation de sititees industriel
bref le quotidien de des des tonnes de
carbone qu'on essaye de de d'abattre et
et en tout cas de de diminuer on peut
citer aussi les ferm éoliennes ils sont
actionnaire de de la ferme éolienne
flottante etolem euh en en région
Occitanie je crois
euh et donc évidemment dans ces
activités là laadem a beaucoup
accompagner l'éolien flottant de de
longue date et et donc en l'occurrence
filiale du groupe
Total voilà pour les éléments que je
voulais partager avec vous et je suis à
votre écoute sur sur les questions que
vous pourriez avoir monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président je
précise tout de suite aux collaborateurs
qui sont avec vous que naturellement ils
peuvent vous passer des notes ou
intervenir pour vous apporter des
précisions si nécessa il y a pas de
sujet et pas de problème de ce côté-là
avant de donner la parole au rapporteur
je voudrais juste juste comme ça sur vos
propos 7 et demi/ 20 on est 3e ou 7e
alors les derniers sont ils sont à
combien c'est le and gaz donc ce ne sont
pas des entreprises qui sont bien noté
sur leur parcours de trajecoire de ils
sont ils sont un vous deux quoi oui oui
alors ou je pourrais vous donner mais
effectivement c'est des notes très basse
alors je dois dire que à date il y a peu
d'entreprises qui ont construit des plan
de décarbonation à 2030 convainquant
évidemment on l'encourage quand on le
voit et cette méthodologie et et je je
je je le dis pour répondre à votre point
cette méthodologie en fait c'est quoi
c'est quelque chose qui permet d'avoir
un regard objectif à la fois sur la
trajectoire de décarbonation à la fois
le le le la valeur de l'objectif tel
qu'il est fixé mais aussi les moyens qui
sont déployés par l'entreprise et mon
point c'est que cette méthodologie qui
est en réalité assez unique puisqu'il y
a deux méthodologies SBCI et sa c'est la
seule qui permet d'évaluer et du coup de
permettre aux entreprises qui le
souhaitent de valoriser le chemin
qu'elles ont fait en décarbonation et la
crédibilité de leur trajectoire de
décarbonation et en ce sens d'avoir un
avantage concurrentiel par rapport à
ceux qui ne le font pas donc c'est
d'abord une méthodologie pour encourager
les acteurs économiques à se saisir de
l'avantage concurrentiel que constitue
le fait de se décarboner le fait d'avoir
une électricité en France qui est
largement décarbonée ce qui constitue un
avantage concurrentiel en en la matière
par rapport à une entreprise allemande
polonaise ou chinoise donc tout ça
peut-être maintenant capté dans cette
méthodologie qu'on a utilisé qui a été
utilisé ici qui permet de donner un une
valorisation des TR trajectoire crédible
en terme de
décarbonation merci monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
euh monsieur le Président vous nous avez
décrit assez bien en vrai à la fois le
volume des activités de total sur notre
territoire et les enjeux y compris
globaux de
décarbonation et c'est vrai qu'on est
toujours dans cette dans ce paradoxe qui
est que Total est considéré comme un
grand groupe énergéticien français et
que on n'extrait pas énormément de
pétrole et de gaz sur notre territoire
et au fond comment les politiques
publiques de fait interviennent par
rapport à un acteur comme
Total vous nous vous avez évoqué la
question des scénaris de décarbonation
avant
vous sont venus un certain nombre
d'experts y
compris madame maasson denmot qui s'est
révélé comme d'autres extrêmement
critique sur la stratégie de Toata et
sur la crédibilité de son scénario de
décarbonation
crédibilité sur la courbe au fond
indiquer un point à 2030 à 2040 ou à
2050 ne dit pas si on va plonger l'année
d'avant ou si on réduit régulièrement
les émissions euh le stock euh de CO2 de
gaz à effet de ser émis n'étant
évidemment pas le même mais aussi
surtout ce qui concerne la la
compensation et là les critiques étaient
étaient très très dures donc j'aurais
deux trois questions qui tournent autour
de ça un
euh en terme de crédibilité d'intégrité
euh de la
transparence de de ce que publie total
comment vous intégrez aujourd'hui tous
les approvisionnements en gaz de total y
compris les approvisionnements gaz de
schiste venant d'Amérique du Nord on
sait combien le gaz de schiste est une
énergie extrêmement fossile et
polluante
deuxièmement total dans sa communication
très largement considère que le gaz
entre dans sa partie bas carbone et
qu'au fond elle est vertueuse à partir
du moment où elle fait du gaz quel est
le point de vue de l'ADM là-dessus parce
que pour nous et c'est ce que nous ont
dit tous les experts qui sont passés
avant vous le gaz ça reste une énergie
fossile que ça peut pas être
considéré si on peut dire à un moment
donné on peut avoir un jugement sur
est-ce que le gaz est moins polluant
moins émetteur que le charbon on a
évidemment des données scientifiques
est-ce que ça rentre dans la catégorie
bac carbone euh c'est évidemment une
question donc comment vous intégrez ça
troisièmement
euh total a a fait combien en 2022 20
milliards 19 milliards de profit le
budget de laad c'est combien 4 milliards
c'est 4 milliards qui sont instruits par
la dame effectiv voilà peu près à peu
près 4 milliards euh au regard de ces
éléments que vous donnez euh la
stratégie de décarbonation le retard de
Total ses investissements comment com
vous jugez j'entends bien votre votre
votre analyse sur les projets mais enfin
comment vous jugez l'idée que de
l'argent public aille soutenir des
projets des activités totales qui est
très éloigné de ce qu'il faudrait faire
en matière de climat et qui a énormément
de moyens privés pour le réaliser seul
et donc du coup ce sera ma dernière
question monsieur le
Président au fond qu'est-ce
quece que préconise
laadem évidemment en terme d'outil de
politique de cadre réglementaire pour
essayer de remettre total sur le droit
chemin sans qu'il y ait évidemment de
jugement moral sur le droit chemin en
tout cas celui du
climat merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur je vais essayer de de
répondre sur ces quatre points sur le
premier on ne dit pas on ne dit rien de
différent de ce qui a été dit précéd en
disant que avec une méthodologie qu'on
considère comme scientifique solide
après 3 ans d'élaboration la note
obtenue est de 7 ou 7 et demi sur
20 et ça c'est bien l'évaluation de la
crédibilité d'une trajectoire de la
force d'une trajectoire donc on dit la
même chose que ce qu'on peut dire les
les personnes que vous citiez
précédemment avec j'ai envie de dire
l'approche qui pour nous est rigoureuse
qui est construite sur cette
méthodologie scientifique qui est
reconnu d'ailleurs au niveau
international mais également repris par
la Banque de France dans c'est
indicateur climat donc une méthodologie
solide donc on donne une un chiffre
au-delà de l'impression qu'on peut avoir
sur cette trajectoire et on la note
alors c'est pas nous qui le faisons
encore une fois sur la base de notre
méthodologie les acteurs qui l'ont
évalué l'évaluent aux alentours de 7 ou
7 et
demi deuxème point sur le gaz naturel il
y a aucun doute c'est une énergie
fossile et donc dans nos cibles de
diminution du carbone on a bien sûr le
charbon bien sûr le pétrole bien sûr le
gaz naturel donc il y a une part du gaz
naturel renouvelable qui est bien sûr
quelque chose qu'on souhaite développer
c'està-dire le biométhane
notamment notamment avec le monde
agricole qui peut avoir des des outils
de production de biométhan donc là on
est sur effectivement une énergie
renouvelable sinon il y a aucun doute
que pour nous c'est une énergie fossile
et que nos nos objectifs de réduction
quand on voit la part des diff
différentes énergies au global on a on a
notamment dans nos réseaux de chaleur
systématiquement des énergies fossiles
qu'on remplace le file ou le gaz qui
sont les deux principales je rappelle
que la chaleur en France c'est 43 % de
l'énergie la consommation et c'est au
2/ers fossiles donc à chaque fois qu'on
fait un réseau de chaleur on combat bien
non pas une entreprise mais on combat
bien des énergies fossiles gaz ou euh ou
fu en l'occurrence
euh sur le troisième point donc sur
l'argent public euh il y a simplement il
a simplement point de des chiffres liés
au gaz de Ch alors nous on dit la
solidité alors gaz de schiste je pense
pas alors nous encore une fois on n pas
fait d'étude surttal hein on a on a je
sais pas si on a des éléments là-dessus
sur la la méthodologie
euh euh en tout cas il y avait un un
deuxième point que vous mentionniez
c'est la
compensation en fait ce qui est très
clair et c'est ce que je mentionnais
dans mon intervention c'est que Total
indique une stabilité à 400 millions de
tonnes euh en en 2030 de CO2
c'est-à-dire une stabilité en réalité
euh qui est loin de ce qu'on pourrait
attendre en matière de décarbonation
après comme je disais tout à l'heure
pour nous la compensation ce n'est qu'un
dernier recours
donc le le le le but pour nous c'est de
la diminution de la de la consommation
d' énergie fossile en France c'est pas
la compensation c'est pas je ne change
rien dans mon comportement et je
continue avec les les énergies fossiles
et et et du coup je compense enfin c'est
compensation c'est vraiment du dernier
recours c'est important parce qu'on a
tendance à dire que si on compense c'est
bon en fait non il faut d'abord enfin
c'est notre position là pour le coup de
laadème il faut d'abord diminu
travailler sur la sobriété travailler
sur la la substitution du fossile par
des renouvelables il faut d'abord
travailler sur la diminution et après en
dernier recours quand par exemple vous
avez des réseaux de chaleur qui vont
être à 80 % des énergies renouvelables
avec la biomasse mais qui va y avoir 5
ou 10 % qui peuvent tu l'as trouvé
d'accord 5 ou 10
% qui vont être sur du gaz naturel bah
là on peut imaginer des compensations
parce que c'est des ajustements par
rapport à des processus de biomasse qui
qui absorb peut-être moins lespqu donc
pour nous la compensation c'est ça c'est
pas je ne change rien et je garde mes
400 millions de tonnes de carbone et je
vais trouver des compensations en
achetant des forêts ou en développant
euh non c'est pour nous c'est vraiment
de la la la compensation c'est le
dernier recours de la transition
écologique pour évidemment faire mieux
que
que enfin ça peut pas se substituer à la
diminution je sais pas si je suis clair
mais c'est c'est extrêmement important
euh
voilà on on regardait sur mon équipe me
me disait sur l'analyse qui a été faite
sur
total l'entreprise continue à investir
dans de nouveau projets pétroliers
gazier contrairement à ce qui est
préconisé par le scénario net zéro donc
ça
évidemment le le scénario net z0ro
considère qu'il y a assez d'extraction
comme ça aujourd'hui puisque l'idée
c'est de diminuer la part desénergies
fossile il y a un peu un cont-temps de
continuer à invest sur la prospection
voilà après
euh ça fait partie aujourd'hui des
investissement et la stratégie totale
qui évidemment pour nous ne répond pas
aux objectifs
de de de de laei de laie pardon l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie donc en ça
ça ne répond pas au sujet dont on a pu
en à la trajectoire qu'on qu'on pourrait
souhaiter euh
je vais peut-être passer au au troisème
point qui était très important sur le
l'argent
public en fait je le dis souvent mais la
France aujourd'hui c'est 400 millions de
tonnes pour atteindre la
décarbonation en 2050 il a un point de
passage à 2030 qui a 270 millions de
tonnes donc on a 7 ans pour trouver 138
millions de tonnes de carbone donc moi
mon métier avec les femmes et les hommes
qui travaillent à laadm c'est au
quotidien d'aller chercher C 138
millions de tonnes pour décarboner au
plus possible et atteindre le point de
passage de 2030 donc nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de prendre les sites les
moins vertueux les
projets au charbon sa que LACI on
fabrique avec du charbon par exemple
c'est d'aller avec ces entreprises au
plus près de ces problématiques là pour
à chaque fois substituer le charbon à
l'hydrogène par exemple ou décarboner
réutiliser de la chaleur fatale qui est
perdue donc à chaque fois qu'on a des
projets qui font progresser
euh notre équation carbone et bien on y
va on y va au côté du monde économique
on y va au côté des collectivités
j'étais encore la semaine dernière dans
une petite collectivité une ville de
15000 habitants qui a créé la ville de
bisvillire qui a qui a créé son réseau
de chaleur mais c'est des c'est des
succès à chaque fois j'ai j'ai été dans
une grande Assyrie sur lequelle le le
massivement est accompagné par l'État
pour être le premier site de production
d'acier à l'hydrogène à une échelle
inégalée dans le monde donc c'est ces
projets qu'on accompagne on est au côté
de tous ceux qui font le choix de de de
de de prendre ce ce chemin de la
décarbonation et on est à leur côté qui
soit une collectivité qui soit une
entreprise donc ma clé de lecture c'est
comment j'atteins ces 138 millions de
tonnes et en fait c'est à porter de main
et c'est c'est ce qu'on voit dans nos
approche là c'estàd que c'est beaucoup
de d'investissement de l'État bien sûr
beaucoup de temps beaucoup d'énergie
mais j'étais encore avec une entreprise
de
l'agro-industrie qui produit du sucre
ils ont un plan de décarbonation très
ambitieux on est à leur côté à chaque
fois pour les aider dans ces
investissements qui vont être
déterminants pour atteindre les 130
millions de donc pour moi j'ai pas de
jugement de valeur sur quels sont les
dividendes quels sont les ça c'est c'est
je reste à ma juste place ma juste place
c'est d'instruire des dossiers avec mes
équipes pour voir les projets les plus
efficaces pour l'euro public investi et
la meilleure efficacité ce que j'appelle
l'efficacité carbone de l'euro public
investi et la meilleure efficacité en
terme de réduction du carbone et
d'atteindre des 138 millions de
après vous
pouvez je pourrais vous donner mon
opinion sur le sujet mais ce ne sera pas
un avis de laadem au sens d'un avis de
laadem qui est toujours un avis
scientifique
aujourd'hui la façon dont le le le les
aides sont octroyés encore une fois
c'est le mérite du projet donc on a ce
qu'on appelle un mérit order on regarde
le le le le voilà l'efficacité la
solidité du projet son impact et on aide
au juste milieu au juste niveau pour que
l'équilibre économique soit soit
raisonnable Thi 8 % habituellement donc
c'est ces projetslà sont des projets euh
sur lequel on a un mandat de l'État pour
aller le plus loin possible dans C C
efficacité carbone et le plus vite
possible sur l'accélération de la
décarbonation et c'est ça l'équation
qu'on gère au quotidien c'est comment
utiliser
abon l'argent de l'État pour pouvoir
atteindre nos 13 million de tonn
objectif carbone
voil certaines régions par exemple me
disent nous on on octroie les aides au
collectivité en fonction de l'effort
fiscal que fait la collectivité c'est
des modèles qui existent c'est pas le
nôtre
c'est pas le nôtre au sens où encore une
fois le mandat qu'on a c'est
l'efficacité carbone de l'euro investi
peu importe si la commune lève bien
l'impôt ou pas peu importe si
l'entreprise fait du profit ou pas les
seules restrictions c'est bien sûr qu'on
soit pas sur des entreprises dites en
difficulté parce que là ça relève d'un
statut et de l'interdiction de versement
d'A d'État c'est un autre
sujet le sujet peut se poser de dire
est-ce que l'argent public doit
peut-être investi sur des des
entreprises qui dégagent du profit et ça
j'ai envie de dire que la décision euh
n'est pas le mandat que nous avons d'un
point de vue technique et j'ai envie de
dire ça c'est ça relève des des organes
de décision alors quels sont ces organes
de décision euh ça peut être mon conseil
d'administration pour ou moi-même ou mes
équipes sur des en fonction des montants
sur les réseaux de chaleur sur les
thématiques comme celle-là sur France
2030 qui notamment accompagne
massivement la décarbonation de
l'industrie là c'est une comitologie
spécifique avec les équipes de Bruno
Bonel avec avec la direction la DGE euh
à Bercy donc on est et et parfois
décision Premier ministre dès lors que
les seuils sont sont importants ça c'est
une comitologie sur lequel on est
opérateur et donc voilà restons à notre
juste place notre juste place
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est d'instruire
les décisions c'est de s'engager et et
je je vous assure que les équipes le
font avec beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup de
détermination s'engager pour des projets
qui améliorent notre équation carbone et
qui ont un impact fort de l'euro investi
et puis le dernier point de votre votre
question
euh
concernait le le la logique alors
attendez que je me trompe pas euh oui
sur
sur la logique de la la la politique que
de Total et les les leviers d'action sur
alors mon périmètre c'est la France et
c'est décarbonation des sites
français donc on n pas de rôle
sur l'extraction de d'hydrocarbure par
le groupe Total en dehors des frontières
et on n pas de légitimité en avant donc
donc c'est pas pour beater en touche
mais c'est pour se clairement dire que
notre périmètre c'est celui-là et que
nous dès lors comme on a pu le voir sur
certaines raffineries où on peut
construire des réseaux de chaleur qui
vont alimenter la ville d'à
côté en captant de la chaleur fatale qui
aujourd'hui est perdu B du coup on
interviendra bien sûr au côté de
l'entreprise qui construit son projet et
au côté de la collectivité qui construit
son projet c'est important parce que du
coup ça change le prisme euh moi je
trouve qu'il est heureux que nos
instructeurs n'est pas à évaluer
euh une entre guillemets euh
acceptabilité de l'entreprise en
elle-même est-ce qu'ou de la
collectivité est-ce qu'elle lève
suffisamment enfin on serait sur des
considérations qui dépasseraient les
enfin qui
dépasserait l'expertise technique de nos
ingénieurs qui sont là pour voir la
solidité financière technique la
robustesse du projet en
lui-même nous ne sommes pas et j'en suis
heureux en réalité nous ne sommes pas
dans l'évaluation de l'entreprise mais
bien du projet et de l'efficacité du
projet au regard d'un d'un objectif sur
lequel
qui nous dépasse tous qui cette cette
lutte et cette cause qu'on qu'on a sur
le réchauffement climatique je voudrais
peut-être pour aller jusquau fond de ma
pensée vous livrer ce qui relève plus
d'une opinion par que ce n'est pas un
avis de laadm mais d'une opinion je
pense personn puisque vous m'y invitez
je
crois je pense que Total est l'une de
ces
entreprises qui aura Laib
d'être champion de la décarbonation qui
pourrait renverser le modèle qui a des
moyens énormes qui lui permettraient en
réalité d'un point de vue stratégique de
se positionner comme le
champion de l'opérateur o gaz qui
choisirait de sortir des modèles
existants et de franchir le pas moi je
pense que stratégiquement ce serait ce
serait enfin voilà je le dis avec
beaucoup d'humidité mais je me dis avec
de tels moyens on aurait la possibilité
de mettre en œuvre ce que font certains
par exemple certaines entreprises avec
les dividends climat certaines
entreprises se disent notamment une
banque qui a décidé que un/ers de ces
dividendes seraient des sommes qui
seraient directement fléché sur des
investissements verts ou des projets des
projets verts donc je crois qu'il y a
une opportunité énorme de stratégie de
différenciation que Total pourrait
prendre sur sur le sur le la
décarbonation elle en a les moyens elle
en a je crois un intérêt stratégique
mais ça ils sont plus à même
probablement que moi d'évaluer leur leur
leur stratégie j'ai été chef
d'entreprise une toute petite entreprise
mais quand je suis arrivé cette
entreprise faisait du gaz naturel depuis
150 ans quand j'en suis parti 30 % du
chiffre d'affaires était sur les réseaux
de chaleur sur le biométhane et ces
changements de modèle je crois que c'est
c'est ce que c'est ce que aurait
l'opportunité de faire avec des moyens
pareils le groupe Total
énergie c'était mon opinion personnelle
merci merci mais c'est votre opinion et
elle est tout à fait notable juste avant
de donner la parole à Monsieur
Weber je voudrais bien comprendre vous
nous vous avez dit que le budget de laad
c'est 4 milliards d'euros par an oui
donc sur 5 ans globalement 20 milliards
ah non non non pas du tout non non
c'était à 2 milliard 8 l'an dernier ça
dev être à 1 Milard sur les 5 dernières
années on va dire c'est quoi 10
milliards je va pas dire de bêtises 5
plus alors 4 plus de 7 et demi oui onou
10 milliards et si je comprends bien sur
les 10 milliards sur les 5 dernières
années en réalité le groupe Total en
aide publique de votre part a bénéficié
de 28 + 10 quoi 28 millions donc 28
millions sur 10 milliards oui oui tout à
fait euh c'est donc certainement pas le
premier à bénéficier des aides publiques
de laad pas du tout pas du tout et je
dois je dois dire aussi que ils sont
obligés donc ils participent à des vous
savez au terme des obligations ces 2 he
il participe à des projets dont certains
également financentf l'ensemble de de
l'activité monsieur Weber
pardon dans la note que je vous enverrai
avant fin février il y aura le détail de
tout à la fois les subventions qu'on a
pu donner notamment sur de la recherche
et développement mais également sur des
projets de de décarbonation de site
industriel pas de problème monsieur
Weber oui merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais revenir sur ce
débat en quelque sorte que l'on a sur
les moyens et sur les fonds publics qui
sont accordés à à Total parce que je
crois que au-delà des des montants on
peut comparer effectivement les montant
qui viennent d'être fait par le
président cararucci mais je crois qu'il
a quand même un principe de base qui
pose problème sur les moyens publics
donc de nos concitoyens des impôts de
nos concitoyens qui sont réinvestis pour
un groupe qui fait grosso modo 20
milliards de bénéfice et finalement si
je prends l'un des exemple dont j'ai eu
20 mais je crois qu'il a suscité du
débat au sein même de votre conseil
d'administration si je pense en
particulier du projet de récupération de
de chaleur sur la plateforme de
pétrolière de de Total énergie en
Normandie j'imagine que que c'est aussi
ca qui a fait l'objet de débat au sein
même de votre conseil d'administration
on peut pas comparer l'excellent exemple
dont vous avez fait état tout à l'heure
qui est celui de bichwiiler avec un
projet de ce type là et je pense que
Total si cette entreprise avait souhaité
être exemplaire pour de la chaleur elle
aurait déjà depuis longtemps dû pu
financièrement pu c'est certain et dû
effectivement passer à la décarbonation
donc je crois que de ce point de vue-là
en tout cas moi je suis perplexe sur les
les arguments qui sont qui sont donnés
parce que je crois que le défi est
tellement immense et que ces moyens
nécessaires pour aller vers la
décarbonation sont tellement importants
pour plein d'autres acteurs que à mon
avis de ce point de vue-là on devrait
revoir notre la copie et puis euh euh
monsieur le Président vous avez beaucoup
d'autres expertises à votre arc je
m'excuse de de revenir sur un autre
moment de votre parcours mais euh je
voulais quand même faire état de de de
du recours qui a été engagé par par
Total le 28 avril dernier qui a assigné
l'ONG greenp greenpiece en justice
l'accusant d'avoir diffusé des
informations fausses et trompeuses sous
les énergies les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre déclaré par Total énergie
je le dis euh enfin je le cite cette
poursuite en justice est assez inédite
et elle fait suite à un rapport où
Greenpeace estimait que le bilan carbone
de la multinationale est bien supérieur
à ce qu'elle admet alors on peut de ce
point de vue-là euh se s'interroger sur
le lien qu'il y a avec laadème mais là
je je m'adresse plutôt à celui qui a été
engagé sur le renforcement des
protections des lanceurs d'alerte euh ne
voyez-vous pas dans ce procès une
tentative d'intimidation euh d'autres en
en fait part euh du mouvement climat à
travers une procédure Billon et cet
acent justice ne vise-t-elle pas à
limiter la liberté d'expression d'un
lanceur d'alerte et n'estimez-vous pas
que cette stratéie cette nouvelle
stratégie de Total énergie enchaînant
des procès en diffamation est une
manière de faire taire aussi ses
responsabilités climatiques et
politiques là je m'adresse vraiment à
l'ancien député qui a euh porté des
textes sur ce sujet euh en tant que sur
les et en tout cas c'est une je sais
bien mais euh ça n'empêche pas le
président d' avoir une position
personnelle sur leou le président ladem
va répondre mais h je le dis tout de
suite on sort du cadre de la commission
d'enquête et je voudrais pas qu'on
dérape parce que quand on commence on
sait pas où ça s'arrête donc ce sera la
seule question hors cadre qu'on tolérera
pour la suite de cette commission
monsieur le Président vous avez la
parole je vous remercie monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur
effectivement il y a deux éléments
importants dans le le premier point que
que vous
évoqueiez on doit être à notre juste
place personnellement je suis persuadé
que de même que quand vous êtes
industriel vous pouvez pas balancer vos
déchets dans la rivière d'à côté un jour
les législateurs diront ben vous pouvez
pas balancer votre chaleur comme ça un
jour je pense que le législateur
s'interrogera
sur est-ce qu'on laisse la chaleur
fatale se perdre comme ça il y a déjà
des nécessités d'études mais ça c'est au
législateur de décider en
attendant en attendant laad est là pour
faire en sorte que ces projets émergent
et ces projets n'émergent pas si on les
accompagne pas et moi mon objectif c'est
les 138 millions de tonnes
l'accélération et on a besoin d'aller
chercher ces projets de chaleur fatale
perdue de de de grand four qui tourne au
charbon c'est pas interdit de faire
tourner un four au charbon si on veut
l'interdire c'est le rôle du
législateur en revanche sur toutous les
fours au charbon qui fonctionnent en
France notre job c'est d'essayer d'aller
les transformer peut-être en gaz naturel
c'est une étape avant d'aller vers
l'hydrogène qui est évidemment nettement
meilleur mais c'est notre but notre le
le jour où le le législateur aura pris
d'autres choix nous serons B dans la
ligée de ces choix fait par le
législateur mais restons à notre juste
place en tout cas notre juste place
c'est à chaque fois qu'il y a du charbon
en France à chaque fois qu'il y a du gaz
naturel qu'on peut remplacer par de
l'hydrogène ou par du biométhane à
chaque fois qu'on peut agir sur
décarbonation on le
fait et donc du
coup c'est c'est c'est c'est la logique
qu'on a là comme je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est vraiment une logique par
projet en fait si on on on raisonne sur
les montants c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup d'argent 28 millions parce que
c'est 28 + 10 à Saft sur les batteries
qui est une filiale du groupe sur 5 ans
c'est beaucoup d'argent et pour
autant notre notre action elle est
vraiment sur cette efficacité carbone
qu'on va chercher et donc c'est notre
mandat voilà après on est à notre juste
place si le mandat change on s'adaptera
bien sûr mais je je je je tiens à ce que
mes ingénieurs soient vraiment sur le
cœur de leur expertise qui est de dire
si c'est un bon projet ou pas qui va
aider à sauver la planète ou pas après
dès lors qu'on sait que c'est un bon
projet qui aide à sauver la planète mais
moi je veux qu'on le fasse le plus
rapidement possible c'est un peu le
mandat qu'on a voilà avec les moyens
avec l'efficacité carbone qui nous est
indiqué et sur le sujet des lanc
d'alerte al évidemment un tire personn
je suis très heureux qu'on poser la
question moi je pense qu'il y a deux
sujets la France est un des pays qui a
la meilleure tion sur les lanceurs
d'alertes la plus la plus juste en c'est
ma conviction et elle a été
votée très largement au mandat
précédent ce que je veux dire là-dessus
c'est que il y a deux domaines dans
lequel c'est à mon
sens extrêmement positif c'est le
domaine de droit du travail et le
domaine de l'environnement parce que
quand il y a une flaque d'huile dans la
rivière d'à côté personne va au
commissariat pour porter plainte et donc
le lanceur d'alerte qui va lancer une
alerte en disant au pied de l'usine là
j'ai vu une grosse grosse Tage d'huile
je pense que c'est et cetera et cetera
euh le salarié qui va dire c'est pas
normal on déverse on déverse ses
quantités chimiques de mercure dans la
rivière d'à côté et ben évidemment il
faut le protéger il faut le protéger et
le sens de la législation française sur
les lanceurs d'alertees je pense qu'elle
est au juste niveau avec des des des
d'ailleurs des approches contre les
procédures billons qui sont extrêmement
à mon avis fines et bien efficaces ça
protège les personnes physiques pas les
personnes morales et ça
j'insiste le droit des associations on
avait eu beaucoup de discussions avec
les ONG le droit des
associations et relève vraiment la
Constitution dans leur liberté dans le
parole oui je vois procédure Bayon de
Total Energie Greenpace demand la condam
de la pour procédure abusive donc le
droit français me semble être
extrêmement protecteur des personnes
physiques et c'est l'objet de la
législation que j'ai faite les personnes
morales c'est différent personnes
morales sont relèv d'autres logiques
juridiques je refais pas le débat sur
personne physique personne morale en
tout cas sachez et ça c'est mon dernier
message que si une une française ou un
Français dans son travail dans sa vie
quotidienne voit des atteintes graves à
l'environnement il sera sera protégé il
sera protégé avec l'une des meilleures
législations au monde sur les lanceurs
d'alertes voilà donc on peut en être
fier c'est important et c'est un allié
de de la défense de l'environnement au
juste niveau au juste niveau à mon sens
on a trouvé une juste ligne de crête sur
le sujet merci je sais pas pourquoi vous
dites que c'est votre dernier message
j'espère pour vous que vous resterez
encore longtemps président ou oui
j'avais compris monsieur Barros
oui en fait on a on tourné merci pour
pour ces propos merci monsieur le
Président on était un peu sur les mêmes
questions je pense tous les trois
évidemment en étudiant en préparant ce
rendez-vous et c'est vrai que on sait
que laadame est un opérateur public de
de premier plan et dans les
collectivités on le connaît bien parce
queà la fois c'est l'accompagnement des
entreprises dans la transition
énergétique mais aussi des collectivités
et c'est vrai que des présentations à
chaque fois qu'on peut avoir l'intention
des intercou des collectivités on voit
bien queil y a une ingénierie il y a une
assistance financière sur de sur de la
MO sur la distance à maîtrise d'ouvrage
très importante de l'ordre de 50 % de
mémoire et c'est vrai qu'après c'est
toujours un peu creux sur
l'accompagnement financier des projets
sur la réalisation malheureusement on
est toujours un peu sur sa fin en terme
de moyen mais ça c'est c'est normal
quand on est mer au présent intercour on
on cherche toujours des moyens
supplémentaires par à ce qu'ils existe
réellement et euh et quand on on
évoquait di tous les trois le le ce le
fait de de pouvoir octroyer à total des
moyens donc en l'occurrence 38 millions
d'euros pour des projets qui sont en
effet quand on regarde projet par projet
c'est tout à fait pertinent et notamment
les réseaux de chaleur du fait de la
récupération sur la raffinerie Normandie
près du Havre en effet ça va permettre
de des une économie très importante je
pense pour les pour les usagers et c'est
un bon projet par contre c'est vrai que
Total est une entreprise très
particulière euh et c'est pas tant c'est
bénéfice c'est en fait c'est sa
trajectoire par rapport à la
décarbonation qui interroge à un moment
donné on peut pas s'empêcher de de
mettre en relation les deux des moyens
donnés à total pour accompagner des
projets qui sont certes très
intéressants et qui vont dans le bon
sens et en même temps total qui engage
une trajectoire qui est pas si vertueuse
et d'ailleurs qui en terme de notation
est pas si extraordinaire que que ça
donc moi je me pose la question de de
quelle efficacité comment on peut être
plus efficace quel est le qu'est-ce que
ça a comme sens tout ça et que que la
j'inversera presque les chose et ça
j'amène ça à la discussion l'ADEM est
contributeur de de projets portés par
Total on du sens peut-être est-ce que
serait on aurait pas intérêt à être plus
efficace en faisant en sorte que total
soit réellement contributeire de laadem
pour qu'elle accompagne des projets
vertueux en direction des collectivités
parce que le Sénat est quand même la
chambre des collectivités de façon à
accélérer réellement le la transition
énergétique parce que là le chantier est
inépuisable sur l'ensemble des bâtiments
qu'il faut refaire reconstruire euh
isoler changer nos chaudières et autres
et
euh vous évoquiez un budget de 1 à 4
milliards d'euros par an de laadem 3
millions à Total bon le fond vert porté
par l'État c'est de de 5 milliards
d'euros et on se bat un peu tous pour
récupérer un peu de moyens pour nos
collectivité euh quel est le budget
alloué au territoire aux collectivités
dans le casadre de la transition
énergétique versus ce qui ce qui est
versé aux grandes entreprises don total
euh j'aimerais bien avir quelques
éléments chiffrés pour savoir quelle est
la situation réelle est-ce qu'il faut
seen satisfaire ou
[Applaudissements]
pas merci monsieur le sénateur sur le
premier point oui l'assistance à
maîtrise d'ouvrage on accompagne
beaucoup c'est un des vrais problèmes
notamment de collectivité de taille
moyenne ou petite c'est c'est le manque
d'ingénierie et donc laadem cofinance à
hauteur de 30000 € par an pendant 3 ans
donc c'est c'est massif
des des des postes d'ingénierie parce
que l'État
considère que il faut accompagner les
collectivités dans C dans cette
ingénierie ça va être par exemple des
gens qui vont travailler sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
ça va être des gens qui vont travailler
sur les rénovations des bâtiments donc
différents dispositifs il y a 700 postes
qui sont aidés par laadem avoir 4000 par
l'État au global dont 700 par
laadem dans au sein des collectifs éité
sur des sur des logiques en ce qui
concerne de de 3 ans le financement des
projets est quand même massif les 900
millions les 850 millions pardon de de
du fond chaleur c'est bien dans les
territoires pour des collectivités alors
bien sûr qui sraite par DSP puisque
c'est c'est jamais les enfin c'est
rarement les collectivités qui font
régie enfin c'est bien pour la
collectivité qui définit une
infrastructure d'énergie pour son
territoire donc 900 850 millions pardon
sur notre budget initatif qui est de 1
milliard 1 à peu près peut-être un peu
plus un peu plus qu'un milliard 1 donc
c'est c'est une grosse part qui est sur
les sur les collectivités et les
infrastructures ce qu'on appelle le fond
chaleur qui qui chez nous est un fond
historique chaleur renouvelable qui est
un fond un fond histérique un fond
historique
historique sur le deuxème point moi
jeais quand même insister sur le le le
le sujet du
Havre c'est insupportable de se dire qui
a de la chaleur
fatale qui s'envole alors que ça peut
servir à chauffer et à baisser le prix
de la facture des gens qui habitent
juste à côté c'est insupportable donc il
faut tout faire pour rapidement corriger
ça alors soit le législateur s'en empart
en disant comme je disa tout à l'heure
c'est interdit mais ce serait très
compliqué parce que en réalité moi je
pense qu'il faut aller très vite dans
l'action et euh mais ça c'est votre
responsabilité de législateur mais dès
lors que c'est pas interdit de balancer
de la chaleur au petits oiseau alors il
faut agir et nous on agit on agit on est
dans la collectivité puisquen
l'occurrence le gros du budget de tout
ça ça a pas été à Total hein ça a été à
la ville du Havre à la ville du Havre
euh
et d'accompagn je crois c'est ça et
c'est beaucoup plus pour la collectivité
j'ai plus le chiffre en tête exact jeis
vous le donner mais c'est beaucoup plus
dans ce qui a été donné à la
collectivité sur l'ensemble du réseau de
chaleur et de la solution est-ce que je
puiser combien 6 millions à la
collectivité et 5 à 6 millions à la
collectivité bon c'est pas beaucoup plus
c'est un peu plus c'est un peu plus en
fait le le mais mais en réalité en
réalité ça correspond à une situation en
France sur lequel il faut agir il y a
deux moyens d'action il y a agir sur la
récupération de ces chaleurs fatales et
il y a aussi des choses sur lequelles on
devrait pouvoir progresser ce qui bloque
l'utilisation de la chaleur fatale c'est
le risque de déménagement ou de
fermeture d'une entreprise parce que si
vous fondez votre réseau de chaleur sur
la chaleur fatale de récupération que se
passe-t-il si l'entreprise déménage ou
si elle
ferme pardon non non mais non mais ça se
pose pas là je parle de la récupération
de la chaleur fatale en
général sur total voilà c'est c'était un
bon projet en terme d'efficacité de
carbone ça a fait du débat au CA alors
je n'étais pas président à l'époque
c'était le dernier dossier qui est passé
avant que je sois président donc je peux
pas vous rendre compte des débats qui
ont eu lieu mais on m'en a on m' a M a
parlé évidment c'était c'était des
débats des débats sur ce sujetl
personnellement ce que je pense c'est
que Total aurait pu renoncer à cette
aide même s'il y avait droit au sens au
sens de l'équité de traitement et de
quoi
oui oui c'est ça ils ont formulé une
demande d'aide ils auraient pu nous
éviter ça et et considérer que c'était
que c'était une bonne action en eu-même
mais je crois que au-delà de ça pour
nous encore une fois la priorité c'est
que ces gros projets là VO le jour et
qu'on les accompagne au plus
efficacement possible et donc il faut
voir les les les millions de tonnes
qu'on économise de carbone par l'action
de l'État et ça je crois que c'est
important et puis deuxième point ben
c'est un peu le cas en fait que Total en
tant qu'obligé finance des projets de
décarbonation des projets de mobilité
durable des projets de transport il
cofinance
notamment le projet sur la logistique on
a un grand appel à projet pour
travailler avec tous les acteurs de la
la logistique sur plus de 200 acteurs de
la logistique sur comment on les aide
dans la décarbonation pardon 2000 2500
2500 acteurs de la logistique je pensais
que c'est 200 2500 acteurs de la
logistique qu'on accompagne dans la dans
le le la décarbonisation logistique qui
un enjeu majeur bah il se trouve que
comme ils sont obligés ils ont de
l'argent qu'ils ont obligation de
dépenser et il investissent dans des
programmes C2 en l'occurrence des des
programmes comme ça cela euh donc c'est
du financement indirect de programme
enfin pour eux c'est des financement
direct puisquils sont obligés qui
peuvent être réutilisés dans tel ou tel
programme que peut opérer laadem ou un
autre acteur bien
sûr euh voilà en fait devient presque un
partenaire de laad alors non c'est pas
un partenaire de laad c'est un
bénéficiaire financier d'aide pour des
projets de décarbonation c'est clair au
même titre que toutes les entreprises
françaises qui le demandent au même
titre que toutes les les les les
collectivités qui font le choix de
lancer des infrastructures de de réseau
de chaleur donc encore une fois laadem
est au côté de tous ceux qui prennent la
chemin de la décarbonation c'est
important après de par la loi total est
obligé donc total évidemment
finance finance
égalementreises 4200 ouis alors mon
équipe me donne les chiffres exact que
je n'avais pas en tête on accompagne
5882 structures dont 534 grandes
entreprises euh dont 646 collectivités
donct 4262 PM voyez quand on voit ces
chiffres-l on pourrait dire que chacun
chacune de ces grandes entreprises
chacune de ces collectivités chacune des
PME est partenaire de laadem et sur les
projets oui j'accepte le nom le terme de
partenariat parce que nos ingénieurs
sont là pour pousser le projet au
maximum pour qu'il soit le meilleur
possible dans le cadre du droit
européen qui du coup par exemple sur la
mobilité lourde met des contrainte
d'appel à projet compétitif extrêmement
strict qui se rapproche de l'achat
public mais quand on travaille sur un
réseau de chaleur nos ingénieurs vont
travailler comme c'était le cas AV avec
la collectivité pour l'ingénierie de ce
réseau avec la récupération de la
chaleur fatale et des ingénieurs de de
l'entreprise comme Total ou d'autres qui
qui qui livrent leur chaleur fatale donc
nos ingénieurs travaillent pour que le
projet soit le meilleur possible donc là
effectivement tout projet de laadem il
est en partenariat parce qu'encore une
fois on est au côté de ceux qui font des
projets de décarbonation pour que le
projet soit le meilleur possible et que
on parlait du contribuable tout à
l'heure on est la meilleure efficacité
carbone de l'euro investie voilà donc je
pense c'est important de bien préciser
les choses parmi toutes ces entreprises
et quasiment toutes les grandes
entreprises qu'on qu'on accompagne oui
on accompagne les bons projet de
décarbonation et on dit non quand le
projet de décarbonation n'est pas
suffisamment efficace en terme de
valorisation carbone de l'argent public
investi merci monsieur le Président
pardon
oui une dernière question monsieur le
Président on lit ici ou là des
questionnements sur l'efficacité des C2E
en général
euh notamment sur les programmes
particulier est-ce que ça rentre dans
vos champs de compétenence d'analyser
l'sincérité euh le sérieux de tous ces
projets de ces de UF qui
sont qui sont censés être un des
éléments d'encadrement des politiques
climatiques mais qui pose qui ici ou là
semble poser de plus en plus de
problèmes au tout cas de
questions alors euh on on on c'est le
ministère qui pilote et il peut faire
appel à expertise moi je vous rappelle
que laadem a deux missions celle dont on
a beaucoup parlé qui est l'accélération
de la transition écologique pour être au
côté des entreprises ou des
collectivités qui se décarbonent ça
c'est la première mission et la deuxième
c'est ce qu'on appelle éclairer la
décision publique ou inspirer la
décision publique éclairer la décision
publique c'est vraiment euh B le bonus
automobile quand on est passé à la
voiture électrique avec un bonus
différencié en fonction de l'impact
carbone de la construction du véhicule
et ben c'est les ingénieurs de laadm qui
qui ont travaillé sur la méthodologie
parce qu'elle est compliquée en réalité
vu de loin ça a l'air simple plus on se
rapproche plus c'est compliqué d'avoir
une méthodologie qui résiste au droit du
commerce international qui résiste aux
règles européennes et qui permet d'avoir
un serveur pour déposer les données pour
et cetera et cetera donc ça c'est
vraiment instruire les décisions et les
travailler sur les CD on a une expertise
technique qui va être à la main du
ministère quand il nous sollicite on on
ne pilote pas euh le le le le le
mécanisme des C2 lui-même donc notre
rôle est vraiment le rôle
d'ingénieur et et d'instructeur ou de ou
de réponse à à des sujets d'expertise
pilotés par le
ministère et je conclurai peut-être en
disant que les les les les équipes de
laadm et c'est pour ça que je me
permettais d'insister la différence
entre l'opinion que je peux exprimer à
titre personnel puisque vous m'y
interrogez et l'avis de laadm un avis de
laadm c'est du travail d'ingénieur qui
est publié on a d'ailleurs un avis
bientôt sur le zan on a des avis sur sur
sur des des sujets difficiles hein pour
les collectivités qui peuvent être qui
peuent être des sujets la vie sur le zâ
le scén mais non mais c'est pour ça que
je le dis on nous on met un avis
technique sur des des sujets de sobriété
foncière des sujets qu'on peut avoir sur
différentes thématiques donc on publie
des avis et là c'est du travail de nos
de nos ingénieurs ou de nos chercheurs
parfois on a 150 chercheurs he 150
tésard dans notre dans notre expertise
euh
euh sur le sur
le voilà donc donc je je je tenais à
dire ça oui sur les programme C2E en
fait on a eu je voulais simplement
rappeler que on a on a plusieurs projets
déterminants qui sont financés grâce à
ça le projet sur la logistique dont je
parlais tout à l'heure qui s'appelle
c'est c'est un projet pour nous qui est
majeur il est financé par les C donc le
le je je ne sais pas
évaluer le le le fonctionnement général
des C2E ce que je sais c'est que les C2E
financent certains programme qu'on peut
opérer et qui sont extrêmement
importants il y en a pour le
développement des mobilités douces
auprès des collectivités qu'on opère il
y en a sur les les la logistique qui est
un maillon essentiel pour la
décarbonation des transports essentiel
donc
voilà donc donc nous ce qu'on voit c'est
les prammes qu'on opère PRM qu'on fa on
estime qu'ils sont extrêmement
importants après la source de
financement peut être différente mais
c'est euh c'est c'est c'est par ce biais
là qu'on voit qu'il faut surtout pas
faire un trait de crayon sur sur des sur
des fonds qui servent des des appels à
projet dont certains enfin en tout cas
ceux qu'on voit nous sont extrêmement
utiles et extrêmement nécessaires pour
faire avancer des
sujets peut-être un peu prospectif des
fois assez large mais qui sont
extrêmement impactants notre
sens merci monsieur le Président il me
reste à vous rappeler que naturellement
on attend vos réponses par écrit oui
voilà pour la fin du mois de février qui
seront évidemment intégrés à l'ensemble
du rapport merci à vous la séance est
par définition levée merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur Merci monsieur
le
rapporteur